[Music]
winter nobody
the cells
the suspicious fac
the way of attack
because from fac it
returns
us just a few
hours
juanes
you have to be chip and raúl
man
of me
you can
the birds
when you see the desire
to favre
yes
the strike
that was over
In the mail
the only thing he has done there is
na
note
ah
ea
quality
already
as now
to the sea
bbm chest
there is nothing
the lack of heat
that is, the
need for personnel
and they
are all
going persie it will be at dawn
morey
then
the mouth there is more it
brings
luck  what a night in it
[Music]
if you are
let's do
i
[ __ ]
more more more more jazz
ya fans
this thing
make
perfect rain
peach pleat feet
thick
who is
but our factors
bagapsh
dad
don't ever
[ __ ]
the hit after
if you go up
download
a cry of peace that  It has
aps here
and then nothing
and
Caracas
so they don't know anything
[Music]
no
easy
earthquake I chose a topic
if it continued
and it was not true
already
maestro
with power in addition to trying
[Music]
yes
today I
will  here
or not
the farc of aspe h
hello
and
punctual
or
ghana
d
in hama
is excellent
but about his death
my being
onetti
7 age
and
cepeda ph asad
[Applause]
winter
here exaggerate maker
we are to narrate nothing
peacefully
and
you end up
numbered
this decade
pakistan is already
good to
reach space
that they get old
they became young factor
of leaving the faith of science has
another the facade would be missing
here
the face
but the one of species
to create the sky tec
good
how bad it
can't be attack
[Applause]
now it  good
ah
[ __ ] why
who follows
the forcón ham
mcfarland space they
need
if they are missing
app
ah well
nothing well no nothing
for whoever is
from scanners
[Music]
here
is the day of the end mayer
current they
chose from the special part
efe
on marches it
serves to  catch
the soft
hammarberg
[Music]
this
more more more
here
will be late
ayón hernández alone
and add
this afternoon sell this mail
[Music
] woke up in [ __ ] hell
the one who  is
eyes